just by talking about my research
trajectory because i think it's a common
research trajectory amongst people with
technical backgrounds like me uh and it
might be something that you can
potentially relate to as well so i'm
just going to start with this um so i
think everyone with the technical
background has thought at some point
well i'm going to build the optimal
noun for such and such topic all right
so filling in the blanks for me when i
started my phd i guess being an optimist
i believe i was going to build the
optimal language and ide for building
interactive user interfaces
so during my phd i built a new
representation for interactive user
interfaces and it looked something like
this um i'm not going to go into the
details about this but i'll just mention
that it's a visual language
spreadsheet-like language
and it looked like that
and i thought you know and still think
that this work is neat and interesting
and by some metrics you could argue that
this work was good
but it doesn't completely solve filling
in the blanks for myself uh building
user interfaces
and actually many of the things that we
need to solve for filling in the blank
for myself ui development aren't
actually technological so in my case i
realized that people often need good
help resources when doing ui development
work or really any sort of development
even if the language that they
even if the language and tools that they
use are usable
so what does a technologist like me tend
to do
well of course we build technology to
solve these non-technological problems
so
in projects led by my former phd student
ian chen
we built a system for asking for help
from other people uh and the the rough
idea was that we wanted to create a siri
for code editors uh this was before open
ai copilot and in similar tools uh so at
this point you know when you wanted to
ask for help and still arguably not when
you went to ask for help uh what we did
was we built something that made it
easier to verbally ask your question to
other people
so you could verbally say out loud
something like can you help me refactor
this code to use
a map uh or or a such and such tool and
other people would uh respond with
messages and also they could propose
code changes to uh your code uh this
tool made it easy to kind of package up
the request in context so that they
could easily submit these proposed code
changes uh and then the developer could
integrate those proposed code changes
back into their code uh and again this
was good by some metrics and interesting
uh but it doesn't completely solve the
problem
uh so then
you know in my research trajectory i
built a deeper appreciation for the
theory and non-applied research and i
decide well i'm going to study these
non-technological
non-technological problems uh which
usually leads to the discovery that wow
this is a really complex socio-technical
problem
and to be sure when i say
socio-technical uh socio-technical
systems are ones where social factors
can influence how technology is used in
complex ways and technological factors
can uh
influence social interaction uh in
complex ways as well
but then i realized that my prior work
for
on building and studying uh wasn't for
naught it did help me understand the
larger phenomenon even if the system
itself doesn't necessarily gain
widespread adoption so i end up at wow
this is a complex socio-technical system
that i can start to understand through
building and studying and i would say
that's kind of where i am now in my
research trajectory uh so i still do a
lot of system building but it's usually
to explore some socio-technical
phenomenon uh and programming is
definitely a complex socio-technical
problem
so i feel like uh
to a lot of you this research directory
might be i don't know painfully naive or
painfully relevant uh but you know i
wanted to share it because hopefully
it's something that you can laugh at or
possibly relate to and of course my
experience is not the rule right so
there are definitely some people that
can stop at this first step because they
do actually solve exactly what they set
out to solve but i think that's the uh
uh
i i think that's the exception rather
than the rule uh and then there are also
plenty of people who are wise enough
beforehand to know to start out here in
the first place
that wasn't me
so that said let me get into it so i've
long been fascinated by the idea of
treating programming as a human endeavor
and the research focus of my group at
the university of michigan has been on
designing programming tools around these
usability needs uh and to better
understand these usability needs through
tool building and studying
so broadly speaking we've taken three
approaches to this one to design and
build new programming languages around
the ways that people think and work uh
two to study and redesign existing
programming tools around usability needs
and three to enable better education and
or support
in the context of programming
in this talk i'm going to focus on some
of the work we've done on the second and
third approaches specifically on the
thread of our research dealing with
studying and building programming uh
tools for collaboration in programming
so i'll start this thread by making two
claims to hopefully try to convince you
that programming is a social technical
problem uh first the first claim that
i'll make is that collaboration is
fundamentally important in programming
now when i say collaboration i argue
that there are two main kinds of
collaboration explicit and implicit
collaboration
explicit collaboration and programming
includes activities like synchronous and
asynchronous discussions uh and many
common organizational practices like
peer programming or code reviews or
working as part of a programming team
but beyond the explicit collaboration
there's also implicit collaboration
where there isn't necessarily direct
communication between people but instead
there's communication through a shared
artifact
so for example the vast majority of
staff overflow usage is people learning
from each other's questions in questions
and answers uh rather than people asking
a question directly
all right right so you you look at
something that someone else asks and
learn from the answers uh to someone
else's question
and i would even include potentially
referencing documentation or using a
library written by someone else under
this category of implicit collaboration
as well
but i think we can all agree that these
are pretty fundamental activities in
programming
my second claim is that the tools
available for programming collaboration
can greatly influence what we can
achieve and i think this is easy to
illustrate with a couple of examples
so for one i think it's pretty safe to
say that without version control systems
like git or svn
most of the large scale open source
software that we use daily just wouldn't
be feasible to build if you were for
example share if you had to for example
share code through email and also q a
systems like stack overflow have as many
of you know become really crucial
resources for uh programmers at all
levels
okay
so in our research group we've looked at
many of these different kinds of
collaboration but i'm going to focus in
this talk on two areas in particular uh
first i'm going to focus on tools that
we've built for synchronous remote
discussions about code when i say
synchronous remote discussions i mean
people are communicating remotely but
they're in the conversation at the same
time that's what i mean by synchronous
uh and then second i'm going to focus on
uh some studies that we conducted with
mixed ability programming teams uh so
specifically uh teams that have some
programmers or one or more programmers
who have visual impairments and one or
more programmers who do not
and just before i uh
get into the research i just want to
note that for a short talk i'm going to
not give a comprehensive overview of
related work uh
and i'm also going to present some
things a little bit out of order in
which uh from which they were published
i just
for the sake of a clear progression in a
short talk
okay so i'm going to start with some
work on improving code discussion tools
for real-time discussions um
so
uh
oh and this was work done with april
weng who's the current phd student uh
and faculty collaborators here at
michigan uh professors chris brooks and
paul resnick
so we wanted to better understand how
people use discussion tools uh so we
don't want to understand specifically
how do people
discuss code and we were also interested
in how these discussions can help future
collaborators who later on join the code
base uh understand that code base
all right
so
the focus of the studies that i'll talk
about
specifically we're on data scientists
however
uh we believe that the the findings
apply beyond data scientists for reasons
that i'll uh get into later on
so in terms of setup what we did was we
asked 24 data scientists to work in
teams we asked them to work in remote
pairs
on a
data analysis problem and we had two
conditions one was uh with a shared code
base one
where they could see each other uh see
each other's work in real time one was
in non-shared code base
the focus of what i'll talk about here
is uh what we found in the condition of
the shared code base uh so in the shared
codebase condition uh uh collaborators
had access to
a version of jupiter notebook that would
sync in real time with their
collaborators uh they also had things
like shared cursors right so in google
docs for example you can see what other
people are highlighting where they're
typing etc and they have the ability to
chat on slack as well
we ran four different
sessions with these groups and we
manually recorded
the communication encoded uh the results
as well
and then after our study we asked a
third participant for every group uh to
try reading the code that they had
produced and this was again to kind of
simulate what it's like to onboard a new
team member uh to existing work right so
uh we're kind of studying two kinds of
uh uh collaboration and communication
one is synchronous while you're working
on the project uh another word another
is what happens when you want to catch
someone up um
so
uh for example one of the focuses of
slack is uh that you have a message
history and that's supposed to make uh
it easier for new people to be added to
channels uh and understand what happened
in the past
uh so
in a nutshell our findings from this
study or at least the relevant ones here
were that one chat messages were often
invaluable for understanding code that
was created collaboratively
so importantly documentation was not a
substitute for the content of these
messages right so even well-documented
code that had maybe code comments or
other written documentation didn't
necessarily have the information that
chat messages contained uh because chat
messages often uh
contain design rationales and explain
things that the teams of programmers
tried but didn't end up in the final
code
so one participant put it i think really
well they said by reading the code i can
know what they were doing but with the
chat messages i can understand what they
were thinking and i can understand kind
of the process behind uh
the creation of this code base
the problem though is that these chat
messages were typically disconnected
with code uh so there are a few problems
so one references in these messages
between participants became stale so for
example if someone refers to line 24 and
they say i think we need to delete line
24 and then they modify the code
then later readers will have no way of
knowing what line 24 was this could even
be a problem for people who are
participating in the discussion uh at
the time right so
uh the code is changing throughout the
conversation
also important context isn't captured uh
in these conversations so for example uh
our participants would often highlight
regions of code when they were
discussing them uh so for example they
might highlight a portion of code and
they might uh in chat say something like
what does this do
and understanding that message requires
that you know what this refers to
so these are problems in every
synchronous remote discussion
remote discussion tool for code so there
are lots of tools that support real-time
collaboration between programmers uh and
they all look something like this
they all have a shared code editor whose
contents are synchronized between
participants and a chat box or in some
cases video for shared discussions
between participants
so in essence the problem is that pretty
much every tool for chatting about code
keeps the conversation separate from the
code that's being discussed they might
as well be two separate applications
so we tried to add a little bit more
permeability to make the chat tools for
uh for more more appropriate for
discussing code uh and we gave the
system that instantiated this idea the
the name chat codes so i'm going to
refer to these features under the system
name chat codes but again these the
system really is just a design for
exploring uh uh ways to improve
communication about code
so the first way that we added some of
this permeability was to make it easier
to refer to specific parts of code in
conversation
uh so we we did that by adding what are
called like references diptych
references to chat so dictatic
references are references that point to
what the speaker means so someone might
say this line of code and this refers to
a specific part of the code base
so in chat codes this is what a ductic
code link looks like
in these chat messages can have links
that point to specific parts of code
when a part when a chat participant
hovers over it
so one of the system design
contributions that the paper makes uh
it was that uh it had a design that made
it relatively easy to create these type
of code links i'm not going to go into
that design in general i'm just going to
talk about the code links instead so you
can see
as the user hovers over particular
parts of the message
you can see that uh the relevant part of
the code is being highlighted so the
specific part of the code that they're
talking about is being highlighted here
one of the challenges with these stytic
references is that
code is always changing throughout a
conversation so these references need to
refer not only to a specific part of
code but there's also an implicit time
in code version that they refer to
so we found that these directive
references needed to be combined with
the mechanism for navigating to prior
versions of code as well
uh so with chat codes whenever the user
references a directed code link the code
window that shows where that reference
is pointing to will show the specific
version of code that that link was
created on so for example if you look at
the part of line 4
after the equal sign you can see that
when the user hovers over here
that part of code reverts back to the
ver to what it looked like when that
message uh was created or when when the
link was created
right so this means that code references
that are created uh now can never go out
of date even after the code changes
and then finally because code is
changing throughout a conversation we
also wanted the chat history to reflect
those changes so chat codes also
includes a notion of change history
and what this means is that changes are
displayed in line with the code as code
gifts
so chat participants can look at how the
code evolves throughout the conversation
uh by looking at the conversation
so here in this example alice edited the
code and as soon as she did a message
saying that alice edited the files
displayed in chat and this can be
expanded to show the exact edits uh so
i'm just going to let this replay one
time through
so again alice is making changes to the
code this message saying alice edited
this file appears in the chat and if you
want to know the specific edits that
alice made then you can expand and you
can get a diff view
kind of in line with the chat to see
what changed as this conversation was
going along
okay
so uh chat codes again i'm i'm using the
term uh chat codes to ref to uh refer to
these three features that we combined uh
i think one of the nice things about the
feature design uh for this as well was
the fact that they these features don't
interfere with the core functionality
that other code discussion tools have
right and uh in my opinion as and as our
user studies chose they also added very
little complexity to the end user
experience right so there are extra
features that you are able to make use
of uh uh if you want to but if you don't
make use of them essentially they don't
get in uh
they don't get in your way
okay so i'm just going to show a quick
video of chat codes in action uh so just
note that the video has no sound uh and
so there aren't any captions i'm just
going to be talking through the video
okay
so in this video i have uh
uh two windows side by side so imagine
that these are two people working on two
different computers uh on the left here
uh is alice and on the right is bob bob
is going to ask a question asking
why doesn't then he refers to a
particular part of code why doesn't this
my map function work
alice can look at
this message and respond so alice can
point to a particular line of code and
say that this referring to part of line
is incorrect
bob can hover over this
to see what this actually refers to
right and so alice can also make changes
to the code uh and as alice does both of
them can see uh that alice edited the
file
uh and then here al says fixed and uh
bob can go ahead and explore what
changes were actually made to the file
as well
all right so just a really quick
demonstration of uh of chat codes in
action
okay so we did three evaluations with
chat codes uh in the specific context of
the use that we studied was guided code
explanations so these aren't
multi-person conversations uh but
that we studied in chat codes in the
context of uh but these were
explanations that involved one person
writing code and describing what that
code does uh we focused on this study
setting because it was a little bit more
controlled and allowed us to get um
a better understanding of or a more
detailed understanding of how people use
tech codes features whether you're
writing an explanation in chat codes or
reading an
explanation okay
so
these guided explanations are often
non-sequential uh so you can imagine
like in a programming course if you're
walking through a complex piece of code
uh you often
you know you often don't want to explain
that code linearly you might have to
explain one part of the code and then go
back and edit that part and jump down uh
and so comments aren't really fully
appropriate for these kinds of guided
explanations so we did three studies the
first focused on instructors that were
creating these guided explanations uh
and we compared the with four tools uh
chat codes standard chat uh video uh uh
video recordings and forum postings uh
and we had four instructor participants
uh so four computer science instructors
uh the second study focused on students
reading these guided explanations and we
compared chat codes in standard chat and
we had eight student participants and
then the third study was a more
quantitative comparison between chat
codes features and those video based
explanations
uh so
again for a short talk i'm not going to
go into any of the i'm not going to go
into too much detail uh in the findings
but i'm going to talk about what i think
were the most important takeaways
okay so for me the most important
takeaways from this evaluation was one
that instructors who are writing these
code uh uh explanations often use these
dictate code references so every
participant who wrote an explanation
independently uh
mentioned that they liked the ability to
point to a part of the code because it
helped ensure that they were on the same
page as the person who is reading the
code uh in the conditions where they
didn't have chat codes they would almost
always highlight the region of code that
they were talking about by selecting it
so for example if they were uh recording
a video they would usually highlight
something uh a given piece of code while
they talked about it
uh two p uh another important finding i
think was that people who wrote
explanations with chat codes as features
were effectively interleaving code
changes with messages so on average they
would write about two and a half
messages and then change code then write
two and a half more messages and then
make some more code changes etc uh one
of the things uh
you know if you've done hci user studies
one of the things with systems one of
the things that uh can be really
interesting is when you see behaviors or
usage patterns that you didn't
anticipate that people benefit from uh
and that was one of the things that we
saw here so one unanticipated usage
pattern that emerged uh with several
participants would be that they
described what they were going to do but
then they would make self-explanatory
code changes and use the inline code
history as their explanation of this
changes
so they would say i'm going to loop over
all the data points and then they would
just write code to do that and that code
change would be kind of a
self-explanatory uh uh
self-explanatory
uh diffs showing it uh
you know that didn't need any additional
comment on it
uh third another thing that we found was
that these code references and the code
history could be useful for future
collaborative uh collaborators uh so in
our reading study we found that because
the references always stayed up to date
uh participants were able to browse the
code history uh so all participants used
the future where they were able to go
back and look at old versions of code
and incrementally build up that code
example
and we found that
readers preferred explanations written
in chat codes universally whereas only
half of the uh explanation writers did
the other half preferring video largely
because it was faster
and then finally one thing that i am not
getting into in this talk was that we
had again a set of techniques for making
easy to create like code
edited code references uh but we found
that it was easy enough that
participants were actually able to
create these references with a very
minimal tutorial um and that it didn't
get in the way of using other chat
features
okay
so um that said uh we
okay so the motivating study that i
talked about initially was with data
scientists
uh the communication aspects of data
science that uh that i talked about in
the context of chat codes is design uh
we think again that those uh uh
communication needs are more general
than data science
however collaboration in data science
can look a little bit different than it
can look in general programming
so collaboration and data science is
really common but data scientists don't
typically have the same sorts of formal
processes as software engineers and this
might be in part because data science
work is often exploratory so there's
often no set goal ahead of time but
they're often exploring what they want
to work on or what aspect they want to
focus on
also data scientists are off often gener
different from general purpose
programmers because they typically care
more uh about the result than the code
that produces it right so for that
reason it could be a waste of time to
write clear and optimal code and
documenting process is often not a
priority
so
um
some of these uh uh
yeah so uh uh april wang again the phd
student that i mentioned uh
led development on it adapting some of
these features to chat codes uh to the
jupyter notebook platform which is often
used by data scientists uh so she
developed a plug-in named callisto that
extended chat codes features but also
made them more appropriate for data
science so april made some key additions
so first to address the challenge that
data science often puts an emphasis on
output in particular uh visual output
and visual output can be really
important in data science collaboration
because it can allow team members to
visualize and discuss data
so uh
april added an automatic visual diff
mechanism so that you could see not only
the changes in code as chat codes did
but you could also see the changes in
output as well so uh if you do
you know if you do one step slightly
differently then you can see uh what's
what are the consequences for this form
of visual output she also added the
ability to to add directive pointers to
annotations so for example one
participant could point to a part of the
graph like here and refer to it so they
might say these data points are outliers
where these now is going to refer to
this uh
is going to refer to this annotation
another challenge that we dealt with in
the context of data science was that
although directed code references were
useful for notebook readers
we found that users didn't tend to
create them when doing exploratory
programming work right so again there's
often less emphasis on documentation
because you don't know if you don't
necessarily know if you're going to keep
the code that you just wrote when you're
doing exploratory work as data science
tends to be
so april came up with the technique for
automatically creating these psychic
references by automatically creating
contextual links uh with a message and
between a message and the part of the
code that a user was editing or looking
at at the time that they sent that
message
so the key insight that april had here
was that recall in this context was a
lot more important than precision right
so in terms of precision it's okay to
have erroneous references right so
people can look at a chat message and
they can tell oh the system inferred
this uh that this chat message was
talking about this cell but usually if
it's erroneous then it's kind of easy to
tell that that
reference didn't make sense but recall
is really important because if a message
refers to a part of the code uh and it's
impossible to understand that message uh
after the fact then it's really
important that you're able to uh capture
which particular uh part of the code
that message is referring to
so again in this context recall was a
lot more important than precision
okay
so in general with systems work i i just
want to have
general takeaways for other researchers
beyond the specific system design
so
my general takeaways for this work would
be my first takeaway would be one that
there's still a lot of work for him uh
there's still lots of room for improving
synchronous discussion tools uh about
code so some things in particular that i
think could be interesting to further
explore are making it easier uh to share
your code in runtime context uh
particularly from remote communication
just making it easier to share that
relevant context with other people that
you might communicate with
remotely uh
also another area that we haven't had a
chance to work on that came up in our
studies was uh in systems that had
something like a shared cursor
there were there were different levels
of awareness that you can have for what
a collaborator is doing so
you know when you have a shared cursor
you can have awareness of the low level
like what specifically are they working
on uh but it was still really hard for
them to build awareness of like what's
the higher level thing that they're
working on right so i could see for
example that someone is assigning such
and such variable but what's the higher
level goal that this person is working
on
um uh
it would be interesting if future
systems could help uh build awareness of
that
maybe by capturing more of the history
so maybe if you could see more of the
history of what someone had worked on
then you could build a higher level
awareness
uh
my second takeaway would be that
relatively simple
relatively simple additions uh for
uh in the context of chat codes these
simple editions were dictatic references
to code segments uh to code changes or
to art out to output artifacts uh can
improve synchronous discussions uh for
both participants and for future readers
right so these weren't complex
techniques these were simple additions
that um
you know that we showed can in improve
uh discussion about code
uh so one thing that i think would be
great to explore in the future is how we
can make it even easier to create these
kinds of references that i mentioned
okay so there's lots more of these
papers that i can't get into in the
context of this talk but i in obviously
you can look at these papers for more
for more details um i said i would pause
um this part this this talk is kind of
in two parts um i think uh i'll pause
here to see if there were any questions
that i can answer on that first part in
particular
i should still have time at the end for
questions as well but i just want to
pause here to see if there are any
intermediate or clarification questions
that anyone wanted to ask
okay thanks and very first part of the
talk it's
really interesting to see this work i
was curious um how does this real time
code collaboration how do these
interactions compared with them
kind of more punctuated
code collaboration like i guess github
or
those tools
oh yeah definitely yeah that's a great
question so um i would say so i didn't
compare this specifically okay so i'm
going to call git in github i'm going to
call them asynchronous um
even though a tool isn't inherently
synchronous or asynchronous but i think
git and github and other version control
systems tend to
be used um
uh asynchronously i didn't specifically
compare them but i would say that uh
there are different contexts of use for
this these synchronous collaboration
tools versus a tool like github
um so
um
uh
the context of use for these kinds of
communication tools where
are really like in github or in git
i should say you typically don't want to
do things like commit intermediate
results or things that might break the
build or
that are incomplete uh whereas in this
context in the context of synchronous
discussions you need like often times
you have to have these conversations in
the middle of actually building out a
feature um
and so
i don't think any synchronous
communication tools are like i don't
think those two things are in
competition um
although i do think it'd be great to
have one system that could handle both
like asynchronous and synchronous
collaboration i i think that they're
very different use cases for for those
two kinds of tools
okay cool thank you very much that was
also if you don't mind the second
question i was curious you mentioned
that in code chats participants tended
to put
some of their code documentation in the
chat
so did you find that that also led to
less traditional documentation like
comments or
um
yeah i guess following documentation or
um was that more of an
addition
yeah
yeah funny enough you know obviously we
i can't comment on like how everyone use
it but for our limited number of
participants um they actually just
didn't
oh if i remember correctly the code
comments that they had were very minimal
um
so
they they tended to leave chat messages
on the whole instead of code comments
um but again i think part of the reason
for that is just because comments can be
great but you can't
really have comments
that really give you an explanation of a
complex piece of code because you know
those comments you know code can only be
written in one order
minus you know i know some ids allow you
to have more complex views but the file
is only going to be written in one order
often the order in which code is
executed or the order in which code
needs to be explained is not in that
same linear order so like really
sometimes to have an effective
explanation you need to jump around in
the code uh and like explain something
down here there's something up here
something over there uh something in
another file uh so
yeah so i think
comments were kind of uh
maybe orthogonal to some of the goals
like they were they would write
if i remember correctly they would write
comments just as like a very
just to explain some very small piece of
code rather than the rather than explain
like how they're building up the whole
example
okay yeah very interesting thank you
very much
yeah thanks for the questions uh
yeah
anyone else
and you can just unmute since i don't
have i can't see who's raising their
hand or anything
i think uh that's all the questions we
have so far
okay okay great so
uh in that case i'm going to move on to
some work uh that we've done with
mixability programming teams so this
still falls in the context of uh
programming collaboration but um uh
uh
kind of a different thread that i found
really interesting uh so this was work
led by molly pandy who is uh my current
phd student and sheila madrian who's a
faculty collaborator here at michigan as
well uh and molly presented this at cscw
um a few weeks ago as well
okay so
for this work we studied uh mixed
ability programming teams uh so these
again these were programming teams where
some programming team members had visual
impairments and others did not um so the
reason that we're interested in this in
was in part because programming
uh is considered to be a relatively
accessible field in stem for people with
visual impairments uh right so like
unlike some other stem fields uh all of
the information or you might think all
the information that you need for
programming would be uh
accessible through assistive
technologies right so it's largely code
based which you can access through
something like a screen reader or a
braille display um and it should be
relatively accessible uh and in the
stack overflow developer survey uh
about
of about 90 000 participants 1 350
respondents reported having uh some
level of visual impairment
uh but we wanted to understand the
experiences of programmers with visual
impairments who work uh in mixed ability
teams again those are teams where some
team members have visual impairments and
some do not uh
so we recruited and interviewed 22
programmers with visual impairments um
unfortunately uh
unfortunately our uh uh data was skewed
so we uh were able to recruit 18
participants who were identified as male
and four who identified as female
so it's unfortunate that we weren't able
to get better representation um
but our our participants were uh
our participants did have a variety of
work settings so some participants were
freelancers other participants work uh
at small startups large companies uh
government organizations and some in
university and research settings
our participants used a wide variety of
languages editors and setups but all the
thing that they had in common was that
all of them worked collaboratively in
some capacity
so our research questions were focused
on understanding what are their
collaborative practices uh and how the
collaboration affects their uh uh work
patterns and prior work has looked at
programmers with visual impairments
largely without regard to these
collaborative practices
okay
so um i just want to kind of give away
i just want to talk about some of the
takeaways that i thought were really
interesting from this uh from this work
and obviously again uh you can look at
the paper for more information uh about
more takeaways as well
so
the first takeaway that i thought would
be interesting to kind of discuss an
overview is just how much more there is
involved in programming to writing code
uh
and and writing code and communicating i
should say
so for example if you're writing a skill
for amazon alexa right um there are lots
of situations where like you're writing
code in order to be the glue between a
whole bunch of different services right
uh so like if if any of you have written
uh a
uh
if any of you have written a command for
alexa you might know that there's just a
lot of kind of setup work involved in
setup and configuration work uh even if
it doesn't actually take that much code
to write the the new alexa skill uh so
one participant uh talking about the
non-accessible uh components of
programming uh discussed this in
particular uh saying in order to start
programming for the alexa you need to
create an account on their website and a
very interesting thing was that after
you fill in the form for instance you
need to submit the form and i have to
spend like five minutes looking for the
button and i actually looking for the
button and i accidentally scrolled to
the top uh then i saw it at the top that
it says submit and so these are some
issues that can cost you time until you
find them so especially now that we live
in kind of a
uh
for a lot of people like there are a lot
of services that uh the code that we
write
uh will depend on uh and so even if you
know the tools that we use for writing
code are accessible the tools for
configuring and setting up these
services are not always accessible uh
and in this case this participant was
saying
as this participant was saying uh
the tools that you need to configure and
write an alexa command are one such
example
another takeaway that i thought was
interesting about this work uh was that
a lot of accessibility issues are are
the result of collaborative practices
and not just inaccessible code editors
or other tools right so you might
imagine that if we just make uh
vs code microsoft vs code or microsoft
visual studio or whatever ide of choice
you might think that if you just make
that accessible on a braille display and
if slacks is accessible etc uh that uh
most of these accessibility issues will
be solved uh but as our participants
showed that's really not the case so one
participant uh talked about
well several participants mentioned that
their organization uses pair programming
and one participant specifically talked
about how when they do pair programming
as a collaborative practice
it limited their contribution so they
said so usually i'm the person writing
code because obviously i can't look over
the shoulder i would like to be
able to do the same thing but it's not
essential me being the person looking
over the other person's shoulders right
so uh if you are familiar with pair
programming typically you have one
person writing code uh
the other person uh uh
either literally looking over their
shoulders but either way uh giving some
form of feedback on that code as well um
and what this participant was saying was
that they were able to in when they did
pair programming activities in their
workplace they were able to be the
person writing the code uh because they
had you know when they were writing the
code they were able to set up uh
uh the
uh accessible technologies that they
needed in order to write the code but
they could never uh take the other the
other role of uh giving someone else
feedback on the code that as they're
writing
um another or several participants also
mentioned um uh
the use of software architecture
diagrams so one participant in set uh
specifically said uh
i i wouldn't know how the components
connected together so i couldn't
contribute there the way that others
work uh was anyone could have managed
the issues of the sequencing
of the design process i didn't ever have
a sequence of jobs that needed fixing it
was always just a single program uh and
that was part of a process that had a
breakdown in it so
what this particular participant is
saying is that um
because they have because they relied on
software diagrams in order to plan out
the larger software architecture uh
within their organization um and those
software diagrams were not accessible
what that meant was that it limited
their ability to it limited the roles in
which this participant was able to work
uh so this participant ended up in this
organization being handed small specific
tasks rather than more architectural uh
architectural tasks
and then finally the third takeaway that
i
just want to quickly overview here was
that many code styling guidelines were
also written with sighted developers in
mind right so oftentimes organizations
will have organizational specific like
code style guides uh that developers
within that organization are supposed to
follow um
but those don't
those don't always take into account
programmers with visual impairments or
programmers who are accessing the code
in a different way
so for example one participant talked
about how they like when they were
learning programming how they tended to
optimize the code that they wrote for
braille displays so they said from very
early on i got into habits that were
brighter that were better on a braille
display so you don't put spaces around
equal sign uh because you could fit two
more characters in your in your braille
display i was always put braces on the
same line so basically
i kind of stylistic uh kind of
stylistically i learned
that some things
that i have since discovered are not
mainstream
there's also information that was
invisible to screen readers so one
participant mentioned uh how you know
their screen reader didn't emphasize uh
in the case of using camelcase variable
names it didn't emphasize that right so
they said it shouldn't be this it it
shouldn't all be this is my name all
lowercase the variable is called this
capital i is capital m my capital n name
it shouldn't be all lowercase it
shouldn't be all uppercase right and so
this was information that was not
visible uh to screen readers and one
participant talked about how they
tended to
put navigation markers that help them
navigate uh their own code uh
uh out of necessity but that were uh uh
but that could kind of get in the way
when they were working collaboratively
so they said i was using the comments
and the separated dashes uh when you
hear a line being read as dash dash dash
uh then that's how somebody would know
up here comes my my next comment uh this
and kind of just as as much description
as possible
okay
so uh those were some of the takeaways
that i wanted to highlight and share but
again there are many more in the paper
uh one thing that i want to note here is
that uh
a lot of participants also mentioned
described how the burden of fixing these
accessibility uh issues whether it's
inaccessible tools or collaborative
practices uh how the burden of fixing
these problems fell on the shoulders of
of
our participants on top of their
normal work so they had to
educate their colleagues and they had to
advocate for themselves on top of all
the other work uh that they had to do
and all these challenges happened in a
context where their job uh prospects for
promotion and livelihood literally
depended on other people's impressions
of them as well right so um
you know uh there's a problem that if
you
do something like ask for help then that
might change your colleagues uh
impression of you even if the thing that
you have to ask for help on uh might be
out of out of your control
okay
so
uh that said um
kind of uh coming back up a level more
broadly one of the things i'll help you
take you'll take away both from this
work and from my previous work is again
that programming is a complex
socio-technical process and it warrants
close examination uh and some of my work
has explored this through tubal building
and through studies uh but again there's
still a lot more room to grow
and improve
okay so
let me okay so i think
uh yeah so i should be okay on time so
i'll end there
uh so i'm happy to take any questions
thanks again for having me uh
and yeah thanks for coming
so we should have what seven minutes for
questions is that right
i'm really curious about how these kinds
of different tools for remote
programming
uh compare to existing
paragraph programming like say
like you know zoom and sharing screen
it's like i'm curious on what benefits
that your program has in comparison to
existing solutions
yeah definitely um so
uh
in the case of um
okay so uh
i've done several
okay so let me focus on uh the
the work with data scientists in
particular um
going coming back to um
coming back to this
i'll just say one so we didn't compare
um
uh we didn't compare the uh callisto
which was the data science plug-in to uh
video chat and shared video specifically
but this system that i talked about we
did compare it to video chat um so
let me talk about both really briefly um
okay so in the context of
callisto which again was
sorry this is going through
in the context of callisto which was
this collaboration tool for um for data
scientists um
uh we again this wasn't we didn't
compare specifically with zoom uh
but one of the things that would be
really challenging uh that we did in
this study one of the things that would
be really challenging on zoom uh would
be the task of actually onboarding a new
member uh in order to understand uh in
order to understand the code base right
so
um
especially if there are multiple people
working
on this code base you would
need to somehow well you would need to
record the contributions that everyone
is making to the code base reviewing the
code history would require uh scrolling
through videos uh if you didn't make
other tools that made it easier to
navigate that code history um so because
one of our focuses was onboarding we
decided that that wouldn't even be a
compare
a great comparison point for this
particular study um and so we didn't
compare because i think onboarding would
just be
ridiculously difficult uh in zoom
um one of the system that i only
described
briefly um so this system where
developers can make a verbal request
and
uh other helpers can respond
with code changes uh and then developers
can integrate that code this we did
actually compare with
specifically we use we use skype with
screen sharing but same idea um
video communication plus a shared uh uh
kind of code context
so in this tool one of the interesting
things that we found and the advantages
the actual advantage that we found in
this tool over skype
was that when you asked a question
or requested help from someone else via
skype there's kind of a
i don't know if it's i don't know if
you'd call it a social
expectation or or not but there's kind
of an explanation that you're kind of
going to stay on the line with them
while they work through that issue
whereas with this tool when it captured
your voice sent your code context to
other people what it allowed was it
allowed other people to work uh
asynchronously on that code um
and it seemed like it was just i don't
know if it again i don't know if it's a
matter of social um like kind of social
grace that you expect to be talking with
other person if you're online with them
or what um but in this case like
the advantage
of this over something like zoomer skype
was that while the developer
while after the developers sent their
requests to remote helpers then they
were both able to work in parallel
better right so the developer knew that
their request for a code change was in
the hands of remote helpers so then they
would go on to another thing
uh and then when helpers finally sent
their response the developer could also
like if it's interrupting something that
they're in the middle of then they could
wait to uh
to look at that response whereas you
can't it would be kind of rude to do
that over skype um
uh
and so
that's not going to be advantageous in
every situation
um but in this case this was one of the
advantages that we had over something
like zoom
um
uh but i i think
yeah yeah thanks for the question but
yeah i think also different use cases
are like zoom would be better for
something like education than a tool
like this would be as well
cool
yeah thanks for the question sorry sorry
if the answer was a little long-winded
okay great i actually had one
quick question uh the quick question i
had was uh
so one great talk steve on the the first
uh
study that we're talking about for code
chat um you talked about the the sort of
context of kind of guided explanation of
some code and i'm wondering kind of in
more of an educational context if you
were to design
some tool to support this sort of
asynchronous instruction or even
synchronous kind of code reviews in a
more educational context do you think
there's different um sort of
considerations that you would need to
have and i'm wondering what what types
of support might be helpful for this
type of more educational context as
opposed to a collaborative
paired
programming test thanks
yeah yeah thanks for the question uh and
yeah absolutely so one of the
actually some of the work that i didn't
get into was more
uh a lot more education focused as well
um so
um
uh
a lot of
anything so um
okay so in educational context uh
one paper that i didn't mention i that
came out recently at csdw that focuses
more on on education is called puzzle me
um and
uh you can just look at like my cscw
papers if you if you're looking for that
paper um
but uh we found that some of the
differences in needs were one uh
asynchronous communication in the
context of education
just
often was not ideal because if you're
focused on education
then one you unless you have a complete
like background of where a given person
is coming from
it's hard to get it's hard to write an
a long-winded explanation at the right
level right so i might write a whole
explanation
assuming that
you know you know what a promise is um
and if i do this asynchronously then
someone's going to read this explanation
and they're going to get lost as soon as
i mention you know the term promises uh
right so
for that reason oftentimes i think
synchronous discussions are better
for education
and in the context of
conversations about education one of the
things that we found is that yes
peer-to-peer or like one-on-one or like
small group conversations are great but
one of the things that you often can
benefit from
in in the context of education is
getting more summative overview so uh in
the context of like a programming course
you might learn more by seeing uh you
know not just the solutions of people
that you were paired in discussions with
but getting an overview of like oh how
did the whole class solve this problem
so like
being able to for example browse other
people's solutions or being able to
um
uh uh
look at and run the code of other
another person's solutions maybe and
write maybe even write test cases um so
i think like the
way like i think one you'd need
synchronous discussion tools but also
you would want um
uh tools that make it easier for peer
learning by um
uh
allowing students to
get more information i think from kind
of the
rest of the classroom
even if they aren't in a discussion um
uh
with that with a specific group of
people
yeah
so let's thank steve again and yeah
thanks so much
yeah thanks again for having me